>>commentatorDavid: We're fortunate to have
Jeff Ansell here today to talk, to talk about
his book, “When the Headline Iis You”.
At Google we can, we can appreciate both sides
of-of news stories of the type that-that Jeff
writes about.
One side you're worried that your-your words
are going to be twisted; you feel that-that
the-the journalists are predators trying to-to
force things out of you that you don't believe,
don't want to say.
On the other side, we read articles that are
just bsB-S. We see interviews where the questions
aren't being answered.
Jeff from his background in journalism and
then advising people how to talk to-to journalists
helps us navigate the middle ground. How to
actually answer questions; how to not be a
stonewall and-and not be-be prey. And as a
result I think what he has to say is-is really
relevant to those of us at Google.
No further ado. Jeff , he's here to-to talk
to us about his book one that [unintelligible]
you “When the Headline Is You” and I hope
you all have a chance to read it soon.
>>Jeff Ansell: Thank you very much, David.
Hey everybody.
>>female in audience: Hi.
>>Jeff Ansell: How's everyone today?
>>some audience members: Good.
>>Jeff Ansell: Good, good.
First of all I wanna thank you folks for the
invitation to be here; I'm very grateful.
Thank you for having the interest to be here
as well.
[pause]
I am a media and crisis communications advisor.
What I do is I help companies and governments
and individuals when they're caught smack
dab in the glare of the media spotlight; sometimes
when the news isn't very good; and in fact
oftentimes controversial.
I find myself working most often in cases
that can be considered tough, high profile,
no win situations. I worked on the Erin Brockovich
case in California; I've trained White House
spokespeople; I just finished a stint with
the Vancouver Olympics.
I play a very modest role as a, as a faculty
member of the Public Disputes Program at Harvard
Law School. I help instruct in the course,
‘Dealing With aAn Angry Public’ which
starts tomorrow right next door, by the way.
And I also have the opportunity to lecture
annually at Harvard Business School in the
course ‘Negotiation Dynamics’. And what
I do is I work the MBA students to help them
gain a degree of sensitivity to the impact
of values and emotion inand communication
on the negotiation process.
So in the time that we have this morning,
I'm hoping that we can share some thoughts;
a couple of ideas about the state of journalism
today.
Also I'd like to chat about why I wrote the
book and share with you some stories from
my days as a journalist.
And I invite you every step along the way,
please feel free to stop me, ask questions;
I'll do my very best to answer as we go along.
[pause]
If I may, I'd like to very briefly read just
a few paragraphs from the book that I think
sets the tone for what this all about. It's
from the-the book's introduction.
[pause]
"Answering questions from reporters is risky
business. Though a media interview may feel
like this great forward a straightforward
conversation, it actually represents a contrived
and manipulative dynamic.
Knowing how to talk to reporters is actually
like learning a new language, and it bears
little if any resemblance to everyday conversation
and it's a mistake for anyone to believe otherwise.
[pause]
It may seem as if speaking the truth should
be enough to build credibility and trust,
but that's not the case. Exposing oneself
to media scrutiny requires more than simple
candor. I; it requires knowledge, training,
and a keen understanding of how reporters
write the news."
Any in my nearly 40 years of experience doin'
this, I've yet to meet anyone for whom media
skills come naturally.
"Answering tough questions is difficult even
for reporters themselves.
You'd think that being skilled in asking questions
would provide insight in how to answer them.
I discovered otherwise, however, in a training
session that I conducted in Washington for
famed Watergate journalist, Carl Bernstein.
In the training, my first question to Carl
was about his troubled relationship with his
Watergate partner, Bob Woodward and to my
surprise Carl put his foot in his mouth so
deeply it came out the other end, and I learned
something important that day.
Anyone can ask questions, the real skill is
in answering them.
So it should be of little surprise then that
many executives and government leaders and
spokespeople are reluctant to engage the news
media. Their concern is justified.
People who talk to the media are only as good
as their worst quote. Though someone answering
a reporter's question may strike all the right
notes for the majority of the interview, it
takes only a single miscue to trigger disaster.
One misstatement to a reporter can destroy
long held goodwill or cause a company's share
price to plummet.
And I think legendary investor, Warren Buffett,
said it best: 'It takes 20 years to build
a reputation; five minutes [laughs] to ruin
it.'"
Actually probably in this day and age less
than five minutes.
I was a pretty aggressive reporter. When I
used to show up for work every day, my editors
used to say to me, "Well Jeff, who's life
you gonna ruin today?"
[laughter]
I was oftentimes about as popular as a, as
a, as a pig at a Bar Mitzvah.
[pause]
Now that I'm out of journalism, I-I've had
opportunity to think about why I got into
it in the first place. And it's-it's funny
-- I didn't see any of this when I was in
it for 20 years, but I became a reporter I
think in part because I-I grew up angry.
My late father was
a factory worker and I recall the callous
way in which he was treated and it made me,
it made me upset that-that decent people were
treated in a very disrespectful fashion by
their employers. And it-it made me wanna fight
on behalf of
the little guy, and being a reporter let me
do that.
I didn't become a reporter right away though.
I left school at age 16. I sold encyclopedias
door-to-door; I was a dishwasher; I was a
factory worker. I worked in a couple of different
factories; I worked in a pantyhose factory
where I-I used to sew the legs in the pantyhose
together for three cents a dozen; I didn't
make very much money. And I worked in a clothing
factory as well.
My parents were-were very upset because I
was supposed to be a professional and how
the heck did I end up doin' this?
And-and one day when I was in the factory,
I-I called in sick because I was able to get
an audition for a local radio station. And
I was 16 years old but I told them I was 19;
I told 'em I was going to university even
though I hadn't even completed high school.
And I did the audition and
I thought I'd done a lousy job and went back
to the factory the next day. And then I got
a phone call; not at the factory but to my
house telling me that I got the job.
So though I-I terribly upset my parents, the
book is dedicated to my mother and father
so things came together.
And by the way, that-that pantyhose factory
was mistreating its employees. I did an investigation
on them when I became a reporter so they got
what was comin' to 'em.
And the other ironic thing is the clothing
factory where I used to be a shipper and used
to schlep all these bundles on my back, they
later provided my wardrobe when I was a TV
news anchor. So it's nice the way things turned
around.
[pause]
When I was a reporter, I was very grateful
to do, to do a whole bunch of interesting
things. There was one story that-that changed
everything for me.
[pause]
It was about a young boy named Kevin. He was
about eight years old and Kevin didn't have
a-a family; he was in foster care and he kept
getting shunted from one home to another and
he was a very, very sad little boy.
And I did a-a documentary on adoption and
I focused on Kevin. And to this day I often
think that if-if Kevin found a home, it's
probably one of the most important things
I've ever done in my life; if he found a home
as a result of that story.
And that's when I realized the power of the
pen and the camera. We can get an awful lot
done.
As one of the stories I worked on, I posed
undercover as a drug addict for 12 months
to expose doctors who were pushing drugs.
And I wired myself with a hidden microphone
and I went to visit these docs every week
for a year; never once asking for drugs; never
once did they examine me.
And I can tell you that I collected an awful
lot of drugs from those guys. I put them all
in a safe because the federal authorities
came to count the drugs after. And I'm grateful
to say that both docs lost their licenses
and got what was comin' to them.
I spent 12 months tracking Nazi war criminals
here in the United States and in Canada; found
a couple of these guys. I got one shipped
back to Western Europe for trial; exposed
the others.
It was most distasteful to work on that story;
I hated every single minute of it.
And when I was lookin' at the evidence that
showed how terrible these people were and
how they destroyed innocent lives, I wanted
to put my-my-my hands around their necks and-and
do the job myself. Thankfully we caught them.
I spent a year investigating nursing homes
where I live. I planted spies inside homes
'cause people weren't being treated right.
And I'm grateful to say we closed up one home
and we got some amendments to the nursing
home laws in the community where I live.
[pause]
I had a great run in journalism. And then
one day something happened.
We were gonna go on the air for the six o'clock
news on TV, and we didn't really have a lead
story that day; all we had was a stabbing.
And I never liked to lead the newscast with
a stabbing because as terrible as a stabbing
is, in a major market station, you'd think
there'd be something a little more of significance
for everybody in the community.
And it was about ten to six and as we were
getting ready to go on the air, the assignment
editor got on the loud speaker and he announced
to the room, "Good news. We have a lead story.
The stabbing victim died." [chuckles]
And the newsroom erupted in a cheer. And that
was the day I left journalism.
And it just was getting to me that was just,
that put me over the edge.
So I thought, "Let me take everything I've
learned in the past 20 years and apply it
to another-another purpose." And that's why
I became what's called a media and crisis
communications coach; media trainer.
I help people deal with the news media because
it sure ain't a natural playing field now.
I know myself that when I was a reporter,
I’d say with great respect to the people
I interviewed, "I can get anybody to say anything
I want." And I kinda feel bad about that now
in some cases, but I was still in the process
of seeking redemption and this book is part
of that.
Because the process of answering questions
for media, as I said earlier from the introduction,
is very unnatural. It can be like learning
a new conversation, a new language; it's stilted,
it's scheming, it's manipulative, and can
be conniving.
But I wanna be clear here, I didn't write
this book to bash the media. I'm very, very
grateful for many of the things I had an opportunity
to do as a reporter. I shared some with 'ya’.
It's a noble calling and I'll always stay
in my head, it'll always stay in my head the
quote by Thomas Jefferson who said, "I'd rather
have newspapers without government than government
without newspapers."
Now there has been a revolutionary shift in
how news is produced and how news is consumed,
and that's thanks in large part to you folks
at Google because the fact of the matter is
today anyone can be a reporter. In fact, Matt
Rudge Drudge said, "We're all newsmen now."
The problem is that we're in a state ofseeing
a continual dumbing down of the news these
days.
I mean just in the last week alone, what have
some of the stories been? Paris Perez Hilton
will stop bullying people on his website,
that's in the news. Bristol Palin was [ ]kicked
off “Dancing with the Stars”; that was
in the news. Keith Richards writes a book
and describes Mick Jagger's private parts;
that's in the news, believe it or not.
And so this is something that's quite concerning.
And there are a number of reasons for this
dumbing down phenomena. First of all, fewer
consumers of news are lookin' for thoughtful
public policy discourse.
We're told by so-called experts about diminished
attention spans the viewers, listeners, readers
have these days.
Newsrooms themselves are experiencing a great
many cutbacks; people are losing their jobs;
you have reporters who are doing more with
less. Now it's, you have some reporters who'll,
who will work for the paper and they gotta
schlep around a TV camera with 'em 'cause
they gotta upload the-the information, the
and video to the Web; they gotta keep writing
stories for the Web; and it's a, it's a, it's
lot of work on them now. And what it is, it's
research on the run and their they’re writing
history in a hurry.
The problem is I think it's just it's just
too easy to become media road kill. It's too
easy for decent, innocent people to say somethin'
that they wish they hadn't said. And there's
a lot of casualties along the way because
it's very easy, very easy to become negative
and defensive and argumentative when you're
dealing with a reporter.
And why? Because reporters approach stories
from a predetermined perspective; it's almost
a paint by numbers approach. And I didn't
realize any of this when I was journalist;
I had to get the distance to figure this out.
But if you look at any controversial story,
it's a predictable cast of characters.
If you have controversy, the first character
you need is the victim. And I'm not trivializing,
but somebody's gotta get hurt.
If you have a victim, it means you need to
have a villain.
If you have a villain and you have a victim,
it means you need to have a hero; somebody's
who's ridin' in to save the day.
Then you have a character that I call, "the
witness" who saw the whole darn thing happen.
And then there's the character I call, "the
expert." And when I was a reporter I used
to try to put the expert into a white lab
coat so they'd look official and be part of
a narrative; they didn't even have to speak;
they'd look as if they were expert.
And then there's the character that I call,
"the village idiot." And the village idiot
is [chuckles] the one who really gums everything
up for everybody.
And the risk oftentimes is that the villain
and the village idiot can be one in and the
same.
And I say respectfully if you look at the
recent BP debacle, the villain of course was
BP itself and the village idiot may in fact
have been the President Tony Hayward, who
of course said a few things to the media that
I'm sure he regrets.
But you know it's not even controversial stories
?
[pause[
that can pose risks. Even good news stories
are or stories [chuckles] that are supposed
to be good news can be problematic.
John Walter was named leader of AT&T. They
held a news conference to announce it and
then one of the reporters says to him, "Mr.
Walter, who was your service provider?"
[pause]
And Walter didn't know how to answer, "I don't
know." And that day AT&T's market cap plummeted
four billion dollars.
[pause]
Now if you were advising John Walter, what's
the best answer for that question? What do
ya think?
>>audience: AT&T.
>>Jeff Ansell: Pardon me?
Okay, AT&T fine; he could get away with it,
but it's a lie. Okay.
Well But we really don't wanna lie to the
media because they're smart and they'll figure
it out and it doesn't look good 'cause once
tell you he wasthey tag you as a liar, it
sticks.
What's another possible alternative?
"Mr. Walter who's your service provider?"
and you haven't got a clue, what do ya say?
>>male in audience: What do you think?
>>Jeff Ansell: Well I'll tell you in a sec,.
I wanna hear what you think.
>>male in audience: No, what do you think?
>>Jeff Ansell: What do I think?
>>several audience members speaking at once:
[unintelligible]
>>male in audience: What do you think?
>>Jeff Ansell: Oh, what do you think? Okay.
I think it’s AT&T sir, am I right? [laughs]
[laughter]
And we’re back where we started from.
>>several audience members speaking at once:
[unintelligible]
>>male in audience: You could lie.
>>Jeff Ansell: You could lie, but it's not,
we don't counsel that.
>>male in audience: Starting in an hour, it’ll
it will be AT&T?.
>>Jeff Ansell: That's the best answer.
Or something along the lines of, "Regardless
of who it's been, it's AT&T from now on."
>>male in audience: Right.
>>Jeff Ansell: Okay.
Anyway it was just a, that was the signal
of a very terrible time for John Walter and
he didn't last terribly long at-at AT&T.
But most every company is one sentence away
from disaster. That's all it takes. Look at
Tony Hay-Hayward, our friend from BP. Remember
his quote? What was his famous quote?
>>female in audience: I want my life back.
>>Jeff Ansell: I want my life back.
Now here's the thing: it's quite conceivable
that Tony Hayward, when he made that comment,
he made a number of other comments.
Let's presume he delivered ten sentences and
nine of them were genuine and heartfelt and
one sentence was, and he probably didn't even
mean it in a selfish way, but he says, "I
want my life back."
Well you don't have to be a-a journalism professor
from Columbia University to figure out that's
the one quote they're gonna use because you
are only as good as your worst quote. But,
and the thing is people oftentimes, they'll
read the paper the next day, they'll watch
TV, they'll see a quote like that getting
used and you know what they're gonna say,
it's predictable. "Where's the rest of what
I said. They took me out of context."
No, no. T they weren't taken out of context;
they were edited.
And that's one of the things I do is I share
with people strategies and techniques to make
sure that every single sentence that comes
out of your mouth is honest -- number one,
and that it works in your favor.
But again it's too easy for reasonably intelligent
people to put their foot in their mouths.
Sunrise Hospital, example, in New York, part
of the Columbia Hospital System.
They had a terrible situation happen not long
ago when a homeless man showed up at the Emergency
Room door and he went to the front desk and
he said, "Please I have terrible chest pains.
C, can I see a doctor?"
And the woman behind the counter said, "Well,
sir I need your insurance card." He said,
"Ma'am I'm homeless. I know I smell, I know
I'm dirty, but I have a real bad chest pain.
Can you please help me see a doctor?"
"Sir, I need your insurance."
Anyway what happened was they walked him out
the front door and about 30 feet from the
front door, what do you think happens? He
keels over and he dies.
He was a young man; he was in his 30's.
So ABC News Primetime Live does an investigation.
[pause]
And Brian Ross is a very good reporter; he's
probably one of the best reporters around
today; -- investigative reporters.
He's interviewing the PR person at Sunrise
Hospital and he says to her, "Well, what's
your reaction to the fact that your Emergency
Room turned down this man because he didn't
have insurance?"
And she got all defensive and finally she
says, "Look it, we're all gonna die."
[laughter]
Now you know, if it you're Brian Ross and
you hear that quote, you know you just struck
oil.
But there's the papers are riddled on a regular
basis with people saying dumb things. Remember
that earthquake in Italy about a year or so
ago?
Sylvio Berlusconi, the Prime Minister Italy,
remember what he said to all the people who
lost their homes? "Pretend you're on vacation.
Go to the beach. Go camping."
[pause]
You know and-and those are negative stories,
but a-a negative story doesn't even have to
be true in order for it to get legs.
More than a hundred years ago Mark Twain said,
"A lie can travel halfway around the world
while the truth is still putting on its shoes."
And that was before television; before radio;
before the Internet.
So how much more true is that today?
And I can tell ya that whether a person is
dealing with a negative situation that's real
or not real, there's a particular response
pattern that people fall into. And you may
notice this on the news when you've seen you’re
seeing people who are being interviewed, oftentimes
reluctantly.
When somebody is confronted by a reporter,
the first thing they do is they stop breathing.
The second thing they do is they stop listening.
The third thing they do is they feverishly
say to themselves, "How am I gonna answer?
How am I gonna answer." ?" The fourth thing
they do is they start arguing. And the fifth
thing they do is they have an out of body
experience.
[laughter]
And of course when the story comes out, they’re
their very upset about it and what's their
complaint gonna be, ? "Where's the rest of
what I said? They took me outta context."
You see what a lot of people have to realize
is that when they're mired in bad news, all
the facts in the world aren't gonna change
anybody's opinion,
[pause]
because bad news is driven by emotion. And
just about every bad news story that's out
there has emotion attached to it.
We deliver the ‘Dealing With an Angry Public’
course at MIT Harvard. And we get a bunch
of people who take the course usually from
the ugliest sectors around. We get nuclear
people and sometimes we get people from tobacco;
the gun lobby sometimes comes.
And oftentimes somebody will stand up at the
beginning of a program, usually it's a, it's
an engineer, with great respect. And the engineer
will say to everybody, "The reason we're taking
the program ‘Dealing With an Angry Public’
is because we wanna help our angry publics
learn how to strip away emotion so they focus
only on facts."
And we get a good laugh out of that.
Because if it's about a battle between fact
and emotion in the court of public opinion,
emotion is always gonna win.
Now with a court of law or in the regulatory
world, facts will prevail.
But most people fight their battles in the
court of public opinion.
And they-they often fight their cause by using
traditional public relations strategies and
those strategies don't work anymore.
Because one public relations strategy that
has been used and used and used is the one
where the message is the mantra, . Oover and
over and over again the individual will repeat
the same message regardless of the question
that's asked.
And it just makes them look foolish because
each time they repeat the same question over
and over again, it strips away a layer of
sincerity from them. And they think, "Well
I'll show the reporter there's no way she's
gonna get me 'cause I'll just keep saying
my message over and over again."
But what I used to do when I was a reporter
is I would feature my question and the answer
and if I asked them five times and five times
they gave the same dumb response, I would
feature that in my story. And so who's the,
who looks foolish now?
[pause]
The other mistake the traditional public relations
strategies make is to overwhelm people with
data. "Well you know let me just share what
the numbers indicate here. You know if you
look at the parts for per million they come
in;" it doesn't work. In part because the
information that people deliver comes from
them and it's not credible when it comes from
them. It has to come from a credible third
party source.
The other thing is that very often people
in bad news are-are-are reluctant to refute
the concerns of angry people. To, they, they
don't wanna engage angry people.
So if people are suffering, very often a company
or organization will not want to acknowledge
it. Why? Because it gives credence to their
perspective; it gives credence to their arguments.
And so it makes people angrier when a company
refuses to acknowledge the harm it may have
done or at least acknowledge the fact that
some people perceive there's been harm.
Because when you're dealing with-with upset
people, there's two things they want. The
second thing they want is-is, "Fix my problem."
The first thing they want is for you to acknowledge
it.
And what often stands in the way of course
are lawyers.
[pause]
Lawyers have the ear of the CEO. And the lawyers'
expertise is in protecting the company in
a court of law and that's why the lawyer exercises
too much influence around the table.
The problem, of course, is that a lawyer will
save you a hundred million dollars in a court
of law and cost you a billion dollars in the
court of public opinion in terms of lost sales
and so on. So who's the winner there?
[pause]
Also traditional public relation strategies
tell you that if you're a spokesperson, never
use a negative word; never use, even-even
if it's a terrible situation.
I was training somebody who was a plant manager,
a whole bunch of plant managers, and we were
simulating that day a-a-an accident at the
factory. And in the accident simulation, there
were fatalities.
And so my question to the plant manager in
our simulation was, "What's your response
to the deaths that took place in your factory
today."
And he says to me, "Well you know we're very
proud of our safety record."
[laughter]
"Excuse me? How can you say that given the
fact that there are people dead?"
And what did he tell me? He had media training.
And the media trainer told him never say anything
negative which is absolutely bologna baloney
and nonsense.
Because sometimes you do have to do use negative
words,; otherwise people just aren't gonna
believe you. If you're in a situation where
there's a high degree of concern and a low
degree of trust, and it's difficult to carry
on your day-to-day business affairs, and you're
on the front page of the newspaper above the
fold, and they're talking about you either
in Congress or the state legislature, then
it's time to use negative words.
And a great example of that would be the JetBlue
debacle of a few years ago when the airline
pretty well came to a standstill, stranded
many hundreds of thousands of customers. After
David Neeleman who was the president at the
time came out and said, "I'm ashamed. I'm
embarrassed. This never should have happened.
A lot of people were very, very inconvenienced
and we apologize for that."
But a lot of people are even afraid to apologize.
Again, why? Because it's the lawyer. If you
apologize, it's gonna put us on the hook.
There was a story in Canada involving the
bad blood scare. Remember when the tainted
blood was out there? Red Cross around the
world was sourcing blood from San Francisco
prisons if you can believe it. And a lot of
people got hepatitis and the AIDS virus.
And in Canada, they held a Royal Commission
to investigate why this was happening. And
the President of Red Cross was appearing before
the judge and the judge said to him, his name
was Douglas Lindores, the President. The judge
said to him, "Mr. Lindores, do you now apologize
to all those people who've been victimized
as a result of-of the inept actions of Red
Cross?"
And the President of Red Cross said, "Well,
Your Honor it's that easy, it's a."
And the judge said, "Well Mr. Lkindores I
think it is very easy. Yes or no do you apologize?"
"Ah, well Your Honor I'm gonna have to consult."
"Sir, yes or no do you apologize?"
And the headline the next day, "Red Cross
Refuses Apology."
Now oOf course he's the former CEO of Red
Cross.
But we should know that very often an apology
goes an awful long way towards mitigating
damages in a bad news situation.
I read about one company, The Covenant Transportation
Group here in the United States. Everyday
its trucks travel one million miles here in
the United States alone. They've got 25,000
trucks on the road and terrible things happen
now and again.
And they have a policy, a new policy whenever
one of their trucks is involved in an accident
or even a fatality, the president of the company
and the lawyer will call up the family and
they'll say, "We’re sorry for what we caused.
We apologize. Is there anything we can do
to help you in the meantime?"
And of course the lawyer for the family is
saying, "Get off the phone. They're trying
to fool you. Get off the phone."
And the company says, "Look -- do what you
have to do. Please sue us; do whatever you
have to do. We understand that, but in the
meantime is there a mortgage payment, is there
a tuition payment, is there something we can
do to help."
And their insurance premiums have-have plummeted.
They're savin' an awful lot of dough.
Same thing with the Michigan Health System.
They have a more forthcoming policy 'cause
it used to be docs and then would circle the
wagon and we would refuse to acknowledge your
problem. But now they-they've seen the merits
though of this way.
And by the way, in-in 35 states across the
United States there is the Apology Act; four
Canadian provinces have the Apology Act, as
well.
What that allows a company to do is apologize
without it being used as an admission of liability
in court. And it's-it's a very, very popular
piece of legislation that hopefully will spread.
Because when bad news happens on-on your watch,
you have to be amongst those who's most aggravated,
most upset, most discouraged, and most aggrieved.
So my hope is that “Wwhen the Hheadline
Iis Yyou”, it will find several audiences.
I hope it'll be of interest to folks who are
consumers of news, who are interested in how
news is-is gathered, reported, interpreted.
I'm hoping as well the book will be of interest
to public relations people, of and spokespeople.
Journalists I hope will find interest in it
although it's many of the journalists, of
course, will-will look to these techniques
and will try to find them when their they’re
interviewing people.
But you know the-the whole book talks about
taking an honest, ethical, and forthcoming
approach to-to dealing with the media so it-it-it
should be something that, well will in some
cases will stymie journalists, but they're
getting the truth nonetheless.
And I'm hoping as well it will be of value
of to students of both public relations and
journalism as well.
And overall, I hope that what the book will
do is take those of us who are right now passive
consumers of news; we watch TV, we're not
even thinkin'. We read the paper, we're not
even thinkin'. I'm hopin' that this book will
turn people from passive consumers of news
into sophisticated consumers of news.
Folks, thank you so much for inviting me to
be here today. I'm very grateful.
[applause]
[pause]
David?
>>commentatorDavid: Questions?
>>Jeff Ansell: Please.
[pause]
>>male #1: First, thanks for much for joining
us, Jeff. My name is [Durand] and I was hoping
that maybe we could reconstruct, I believe
her name was Shirley Sherrod, the woman who
had given a speech about not wanting to have
lent dollars to a white family; Shirley herself
was an African American.
Then she went on to say that she realized,
had a moment of mindfulness, and-and realized
that she was imparting some bias and-and did
grant the family the-the dollars they needed.
>>Jeff Ansell: Right.
>>male #1: And then the video was subsequently
heavily edited to in fact make her look like
a racist.
>>Jeff Ansell: Yeah.
>>male #1: You could say the same, the same
thing happened with ACORN recently, right
with the-the pimp coming in with his prostitute
and-and making it look like ACORN was helping
them when in fact ACORN was supplying or gathering
information to supply to the police.
I'm wondering in this world of-of YouTube
and really heavy editing where in fact you
can make an apple look like an orange, what
advice do you have to CEO's or to those who
are in the, in the public media to make sure
that their true message is coming through?
Because once the damage is done, it's done,
right?
>>Jeff Ansell: Thank you, Durand.
Well first of all, learn how to do it. Because
you get intelligent, articulate people who
think that because their they’re glib and
they present well that they know how to communicate
with media, and so they're the ones who often
put their foot in their mouths the deepest.
In the, in the case of that woman it was a
matter of context. Now the reporters chose
to focus on that particular quote that said
she was gonna deny the loan and of course
they didn't feature the-the-the-the other
quotes as well.
The-the secret is to make every sentence out
of your mouth exist as what I call, "a standalone
statement."
You see you can answer a question with four
sentences.
The problem oftentimes is sentence number
one makes no sense until you hear sentence
number two, which by itself is incomplete
until you hear sentence number three, and
then the whole thing is tied together in sentence
number four.
And then you open the paper tomorrow and you
only see yourself delivering sentence number
two and you say, of course, "Where's the rest
of what I said. They took me out of context."
You see when ya, as a spokesperson, when you
weave your sentences together you're building
a house of cards. 'Cause you never know which
one, two, three, or four quotes the journalist
is gonna use.
So the idea, I believe, is to create standalone
statements that exist as silos. So that the
message I'm delivering now makes sense regardless
of whether you hear what I said before or
whether you hear what I say after. Each sentence
has to be able to make sense on its own.
So Durand, that's probably the best way to
have some degree of influence over the way
stories are edited.
[pause]
>>male #2: Hey, Jeff. Thanks for coming, once
again.
Name's Patrick.
I hope I'm not too presumptuous but I'm gonna
consider you an-an old school journalist.
And --
>>Jeff Ansell: I've been called worse.
>>male #2: and going off that I'd really love
to get your opinion on kind of bouncing off
during thisDurand’s question with the rise
of your Glenn Beck's, your Rachel Maddow's,
these kind of journalists, but I would say
new school or kind of what you touched on
with YouTube and anyone can kinda be a journalist.
Do you think that we're losing the credible
discourse that kind of was present in your
heyday and subsequently we're losing the-the
fourth estate kinda we're seeing the death
of the fourth estate in the 21st century?
>>Jeff Ansell: I think, Patrick, to a certain
extent we are.
Part of this dumbing down of news is turning
news into entertainment and the Glenn Beck's
of this world and others have seized the spotlight.
There is very little thoughtful public policy
discussion on the TV anyway. Maybe you'll
catch an hour or two on Sunday morning, but
even CNN isn't terribly deep these days.
And the journalists themselves have turned
everything into a sporting contest. Like we
have an election happening here in the United
States tomorrow. Where's the thoughtful discussion
about the issues; : poverty, hunger, education?
It-it's like a sporting contest; . Tthere's
gonna be winners and losers; smart and stupid;
competent and incompetent. That's the way
the world interprets these days.
And reporters also there's, I-I'm not saying
it was right, but there was a time when certain
matters were off limits. And again, I'm not
saying that they should have done this: President
Kennedy's sex life, for instance.
And now look we know too much detail about
President Clinton and his own particular sex
life.
So there's no boundaries anymore. And that's,
that I find very, very disturbing.
And we don't see enough venues for thoughtful-thoughtful
journalism these days. Especially with all
the job cuts that are takin' place. People
are losin' their jobs left, right, and center
in newsrooms. And they're having to rely on
wire services and so on. and sSo everybody's
gettin' the same news. T; there's not a proliferation
of different opinion out there. And we the
people are suffering as a result.
>>male #2Patrick: Well people say they're
getting the best news from the Ccomedy Cchannels,
which is sad but true actually.
>>Jeff Ansell: Did you see President Obama
on Jon Stewart show last week? Unbelievable.
The President of the United States is on the
Ccomedy Cchannel doing an interview with Jon
Stewart.
It's a, it's a hoot to watch. The President
was totally defensive, was totally without
humor, and the messages he delivered just
failed to resonate on that particular program.
Stewart to his credit knows he's a comedian.
So he was tryin' to make jokes, but the President
just wasn't connecting. And that's-that's
a problem he's having these days.
But that's how desperate people are to get
their message out that they'll go to where
they think the people are listening. In that
case it's the cComedy Cchannel.
>>male #3: So speaking of that, what did you
think of Eric, what did you think of Eric
Schmidt on Colbert?
>>Jeff Ansell: I didn't see that. Forgive
me. Can you share?
[pause]
>>male #3: Well the greatest one was Colbert
gave him this-zing, this zinger line where
he said, "Well didn't you say that-that teenagers
around age 15 should be able to give up their
whole past and start fresh?" And Schmidt listened
looks at him and said, "That was a joke."
[pause]
But I, but I had another question.
How do you deal with the kind of reporter
who basically has written the story first,
knows what your opinion is, has cast you in
a role, and then sort of whatever you say
is gonna be quote edited to reinforce that?
>>Jeff Ansell: We can't control how the reporter
writes your story. What we can control are
the quotes that come out of our mouths. And
if, yes they do paint by numbers. T, they
paint by numbers because there's a lot of
demand on them and they gotta cover quite
a few stories, and so very often they leave
a slot open for the villain or the village
idiot. And they ask questions that are designed
to bring out the villain or the fact that
person is incompetent.
If a, if a spokesperson recognizes that that's
the game that's being played and is taking
an honest, forthcoming approach, even though
they are being targeted as the villain or
the village idiot, they can represent themselves
appropriately without puttin' their foot deep
in their mouths; without putting their foot
in their mouths at all.
You see what's really important, I think,
is for every spokesperson who's mired in a
bad news situation always to start off by
askin' themselves, "What am I made of? What
are the words that I would use to describe
how I want my stakeholders to see me and perceive
me as I deal with this terrible situation?"
So let's say we're dealing with BP or Toyota.
BP: "What are the words that describe how
we want our stakeholders to see us?" What
are the words folks?
[pause]
>>female in audience: Resilient.
>>Jeff Ansell: Resilient?
>>male in audience: Strong.
>>Jeff Ansell: Strong.
>>male in audience: Responsible.
>>Jeff Ansell: Well here's the thing: who's
the audience?
>>female in audience: [unintelligible]Compassion.
>>Jeff Ansell: I'm gonna say I'm gonna lean
towards compassion because here's the deal.
At the height of the crisis, BP's audience
– it’s gotis a different audiences 'cause
it's got its shareholders and investors, yes,
but it's got the general public as well. And
what's said in the general public wasis gonna
influence what happens to the share price
and whether people are gonna feel comfortable
investing in the company.
So I think at a time like this, words like
“compassion”, “trustworthy”, “accountable”
are words that are important. I think that
for the shareholders and those messages “strong”,
“resilient” are very important.
But even then there has to be a degree of
acknowledgement of the terrible thing that's
taken place.
And then the idea is to take every message
you deliver, every question you answer, every
policy you have responsibility for, and to
filter it through this prism. Because what
this does is it gives you a path, it gives
you a plan, it gives you a direction. And
at the end of the day, they're not gonna love
'ya. Spillin' Spilled all this oil, we ain't
gonna love 'ya, but if maybe the general public
hates the company just a little bit less,
then that's the victory.
[pause]
Please.
>>male #4: I have a question. I'd-I'd like
your reaction to this opinion that someone
I know who grew up under Communism has of
the, of the American journalism system who
said, "You know people in America in our opinion
are much more easily influenced by the media
because they grew up with trainingtrained
to believe that we have a free press. Under
Communism we all knew that it was all lies
[laughs]."
[pause]
>>Jeff Ansell: I really do believe we have
a free press here.
The problem is that it's what we're being
fed these days in the press.
[pause]
That's why it's-it's good to have a variety
of sources for your news not to depend on
any one particular news outlet.
[pause]
>>male #5: So is the best media strategy to
kind of bond to this existing paradigm of
winners and losers and to portray yourself
as this winner or as the subject of media
attention is-is the onus on you to call out
the confidence, to try to broaden the conversation
and to call it out? I guess I'm not articulating
this very --
>>Jeff Ansell: No you are.
>>male #5: Who's Whose responsibility is it
to question this paradigm? Obviously the person
answering a media inquiry is the person foremost,
self interest in, but is there a responsibility
to address the larger pocket?
>>Jeff Ansell: It depends on the situation.
If it's a situation that's societal and is
systemic perhaps there may be an opportunity
to broaden the context. But if it's a company
that's smack dab mired in the middle of a
problem that it owns, it just has to do its
very best to come out of it.
But these are questions that we as-as consumers
of the news oughta be asking as well. 'Cause
reporters sure as heck don't have time to
ask themselves these questions; they're too
busy gettin' the story out for the, churning
out sausages for the next meal. But these
are important questions that spokespeople
have to ask and that we, those of us who consume
the news, have to ask as well.
[pause]
>>male #6: Jeff, do you have any particular
insights on Google's image in the press these
days? We’ve have had a lot of conflict in
the press you could say; predatory seeming
stories.
>>Jeff Ansell: Well I heard of one story that
received some coverage involving a breach
of trust [ ]—David? -- that had taken place
and I didn't hear about from the media, I
heard it about through word of mouth. And
it didn't become big news to-to Google's benefit.
But when bad news happens, you have to be
the one who's most aggrieved, as I said earlier,
most outraged.
Very often when a company tries to defend
itself in the court of public opinion, when
an ugly issue, something blatantly wrong takes
place, the story starts off on the front section
on page 12. And then as they continue not
to own it, it moves to page 8eight; still
not gonna own it, it moves to page 4four;
still refusing to own it, it moves to page
1one, top of the fold. And you know what happens
then? They own it.
[pause]
So perhaps this particular organization was
got off on a very, got off in a very easy
way in dealing with that particular situation
'cause I never heard about it in the media.
T, but that's ultimately what a company wants.
[pause]
Durand.
>>Durand: Maybe a philosophical question,
but why does the bad always win? On that day
that you left broadcasting, I could imagine
that there were hundreds of other good things
that happened, but why do you think the bad
always-always takes the top story?
>>Jeff Ansell: I think it's for the same reason
that people slow their cars to look at accidents
on the highway on the other side; because
there's that curiosity.
[pause]
In the case of the, of the newsroom though,
it's just an insensitivity.
[pause]
Reporters are faced up every day with terrible
things in life and so some of them fight back
by becoming insensitive to it.
I know that when I was a reporter, one of
the things they used to ask me to do was if
somebody experienced a death in the family
due to a murder or some terrible accident,
they used to ask me to go to the house to
get a picture of the deceased so we'd have
it for tomorrow's paper or tonight's news.
And I used to do it and I used to feel terrible.
I was like 19, 20 years old. And then as I
got older I realized this is wrong. The last
person in the world that this family wants
to see right now is the media.me.
And it got to a point where I refused to go.
I said, "I'm not gonna goin'. I'm not doin'
it. No, I'm not coverin' the funeral. I'm
not gonna do it."
Because there is that insensitivity and what
is, what is news? News is drama; it's irony;
it's controversy; it's emotion; it's conflict
above all. News very rarely is good news.
I mean unless that there's a breakthrough
with cancer medications and so on, but most
news isn't that good. And that's why people
buy the papers and that's why people tune
into the news.
[pause]
>>commentatorDavid: If there are no other
questions now, let's wrap up.
Thank you very much, Jeff.
[applause]
[unintelligible]
Thanks.